series it has not worked we're hoping it
would fit into the recruiting profile
easier to get the edge guys he's got a
big shot up there it's Addison again
Jordan and has to just like that beats
Caillou blue Kelly had 75 to the house
put their free safety on this slot
receiver which takes him out of the play
see him go over this on this Crosser now
you've got the post behind it and
there's nobody left in the middle of the
field he goes up and over this free
safety it's one on one and that is a
great throw by Caleb Williams and that
is a tough ass by Blue Kelly to have to
stay with Jordan Addison you know chose
a physicality there to be able to pull
out of that potential tackle but great
route great timing and outstanding
execution in these three series scored
on their first six possessions last week
really done a good job taking care of
the football
Caleb Williams taking a shot at Addison
is wide open and he's Tracked Down by
Patrick Fields but not before another
huge pass paper this is him in that slot
safety comes up now he's got one on one
and he's really known for so many
different things again he wins the
politicoff is a top receiver last year
he's explosive you can see he runs great
routes you know a guy that's on
[Applause]
Williams comes it up the sideline card
what a throw
[Music]
and he put that one on the money
Blaylock ushers him out of bounds after
a gain of 55. over the outstretched arm
of John Humphrey waffles right into
Jordan Madison on the sideline that was
an unbelievable throw
Caleb Williams
Sans pressure
the throw is wide open Jordan audison a
bust again in USA lives
there was a fall down this is good on
good best on best and it's Clark
Phillips that falls down
other times it's been eyes that have
been lost this is just a one-on-one and
we have been clamoring for the
balitnikov award winner from a season
ago to rise to the occasion and that's
exactly what Addison does
in this game ain't going anywhere